[Music]
has beaten Jaya bolsonaro in the
Brazilian election by a razor fifth
margin
after a tense and violent campaign Lula
won with 50.9 to bolsonaro's 49.1
percent the closest result since
Brazil's return to democratic elections
in the 1980s in protest at the outcome
bolsonaro supporting truckers blocked
highways across the country but the
president has stayed unusually quiet
what happens now and what does it mean
for Brazil and the world
[Music]
as Lula supporters packed Avenida
Paulista and celebrated the results of
the election All Eyes turned to
bolsonaro who at the end of the evening
still hadn't said anything publicly
about the results of the election
he has created doubt for months in the
electronic voting system and suggested
he wouldn't accept defeat if he loses
however a lot of his closest allies
Congress people and governors and so on
came out and accepted the result this is
a good sign it means that maybe
bolsonaro will find it harder to create
some claim of fraud which would be bogus
so far on social media like telegram
bolsonaro supporters are sort of split
between a sense of resignation people
saying you know it's time for me to move
to another country and these sort of
conspiracy theories that there must be
something fishy in the result I think
they're waiting for a sign from their
leader and you know we have to wait and
see what bolsonaro himself says
Lula only won by just above 2 million
votes so just under half of the
electorate voted for bolsonaro in some
cases this was due to rejection of Lula
and a belief that he's corrupt just a
few years ago he was in prison for
convictions related to the lava Jato
corruption Scandal these convictions
were annulled by the Supreme Court but
Lula's Legacy is still tainted in the
eyes of many Brazilians in some cases
support for bolsonaro was due to his
tough on crime rhetoric or he is
conservative when it comes to religion
but you know in any case I think the
support shows that for Brazil right-wing
populism is still a very powerful force
it's going to be present in Brazilian
Society along with bolsonarismo for some
Years yet Lula is going to have to build
alliances in a Congress that is more
bolsonarista than the last time around
and he's going to have to try to find
ways to pacify society as well which is
very divided even more so after a
vicious and violence-filled campaign
[Music]
the real hope with Lula is that he can
curb deforestation in the Amazon
rainforest which spiked under gyro
bolsonaro Lula has said that he's going
to crack down on illegal logging and
Mining and other activities that are
responsible for logging in the Amazon
and there's hope that this kind of
effort can help slow deforestation which
is incredibly important for curbing
climate change Joe Biden very quickly
came out and released a statement
recognizing Lula's Victory and he was
followed by other world leaders the
quickness with which they came forward
with these statements I think was really
intended to show that there would be no
support whatsoever for bolsonaro to
claim fraud and so I think you know
that's another factor that is going to
try to push bolsonaro to accept this
result
you can read more of our Brazil election
coverage by clicking on the link thanks
for watching and don't forget to
subscribe
[Music]